welcome everybody to Long crime daily
I'm Jesse Weber an NBA icon was arrested
and booked into jail in Washington state
on Wednesday accused of shooting at
another man in a mall parking lot the
Tacoma Police Department says that Sean
Kemp was booked into jail on a felony
charge Camp was a first round pick in
the NBA draft and played professional
basketball for the Seattle SuperSonics
from 1989 to 1997. sources close to Kemp
say he had items stolen from his car on
Tuesday and tracked his phone to the
Tacoma Mall on Wednesday when he
approached the car where he thought his
property might be he says the man inside
shot at him and he fired back in
self-defense now this happened just
before 2PM local time near a tire shop
outside the mall fortunately no one was
hurt at last check Kemp is being held
without bond joining me now are my
co-hosts legal analyst defense attorney
Brian buckmeyer former trial Attorney
Terry Austin it's good to see you both
Terry so many open questions here the
you think law enforcement made an arrest
maybe too soon what else should they
have been looking into I definitely
think it was too soon look I can't wait
it for the police to come he didn't try
to flee the other car did flee and so
you could say that he didn't have any
culpability there because he wanted to
report what happened also I think the
police should have been investigating
those bullets there must have been shell
casings it's difficult to determine who
shot first but if he actually was
shooting back because someone shot at
him they should be looking at the phone
and tracing all of that there's no
reason that they had to immediately
arrest him in my opinion unless they had
all of the evidence to show that perhaps
he is guilty I don't think it's all
there yet well I mean probable cause I
mean Brian all this is over a tracking a
stolen phone are there any defenses here
and by the way any suggestions for
people who find themselves in the
similar situation so Jesse I'll answer
in the reverse first I understand it's
your property you want to go and get it
quickly but freak things like this can
happen where the person who steals your
devices or other items they have a
weapon they maybe confront to you I say
that your items are not worth your life
call law enforcement give them the
tracking number let them go out there in
terms of defenses right off the bat I'm
seeing self-defense someone shoots you
you're allowed to shoot back at them
guarantee maybe this uh this weapon is
properly licensed so he's not going to
have that issue but I also see a defense
of property it's not just him defending
himself but him trying to recover items
that were stolen of him the person
shooting at him doesn't have a
necessarily a defense could work out his
favor just a really unfortunate
situation to think about how it
escalated into this well this is
something you never see every day a
Mexican drug cartel is reportedly
apologizing after some of its members
kidnapped four Americans and killed with
killing two of them four Americans drove
from South Carolina to Mexico last week
for one of them to get cosmetic surgery
this is according to Mexican officials
and during that trip they found
themselves in the midst of a deadly
shootout they were eventually kidnapped
and thrown in the back of a pickup truck
by heavily armed men the deceased
victims have been identified as Shaheed
Woodard and zendell brown the surviving
victims Latavia McGee and Eric Williams
they've been returned to the United
States Mexican sources told the
Associated Press that the cartel turned
in some of its own men that's right five
men were found bound with a letter of
apology next to them citing the
suspect's lack of discipline and
Disobedience of cartel rules all right
well we are in verdict watch for three
men accused of killing Rising rap star
xxxtentacion whose real name is Jose
onfroy the Florida jury began its
deliberations on Wednesday afternoon
onfry was gun on Freud was gunned down
during a robbery in 2018 while he was
leaving a motorcycle dealership
prosecutors believe defendants Michael
Boatright and Trayvon Newsom carried out
the attack while a third defendant
Diedrich Williams drove the SUV that was
used to facilitate the crime there is a
fourth co-defendant Robert Allen who
pleaded guilty to second-degree murder
and robbery charges in exchange for a
possibly reduced sentence in the first
week of trial Allen testified against
his alleged co-conspirators and during
closing arguments Michael boatwright's
attorney pointed out that the evidence
tying his client to the crime came from
a criminal
only evidence only evidence that puts a
gun in Michael's hand
or has Michael participate in this
murder at all is
cannot face extension
convicting and innocent person
doesn't bring anybody Justice there's so
much evidence besides Robert Allen that
you can rely on
that's credible that's quality evidence
that you can convict these three
co-defendants for
I didn't rest my hat on Robert Allen I
didn't rest my case on Robert Allen I
know who Robert Allen is
[Music]
well to end Today's Show we're going to
be talking about Tiger Woods but off the
golf course you see the famous athlete
has been hit with a very expensive
lawsuit by his ex-girlfriend Erica
Herman circuit court documents in Martin
County Florida show an initial lawsuit
was filed in October for a whopping 30
million dollars the couple had dated for
six years and they officially broke up
last fall Herman claims that an oral
agreement was in place letting her stay
at the golfer's home rent free in
exchange for quote valuable services but
Herman accuses Tigers Associates of
convincing her to take a short vacation
without tiger so that they could then
lock her out of the house for good and
the drama really doesn't stop there no
because another legal filing from
Hermann involves a non-disclosure
agreement that tiger lid allegedly made
her sign on Monday she filed a complaint
to nullify it citing the federal speak
out act and that prohibits ndas if
there's any evidence of sexual
harassment or assault she says that a
private Trust of tigers is trying to
stop her from sharing any relationship
related details but there hasn't been
any indications so far that there were
crimes of sexual nature so Terry can you
break down these complaints for us what
exactly is Erica Hermann claiming you
know it's interesting both of these
cases are civil cases and they're both
in Florida State Court but that's where
the similarities stop right there the
first case that you mentioned is a case
they're suing the trust they're not
actually suing Tiger Woods himself and
they're suing the trust saying that that
oral agreement was I can stay in this
house for an additional five years
because of all of these services that
I'm you know performing it didn't list
the exact services so you have to wonder
what's going on there but the trust is
claiming that it's just an argument
between the two of them and there was no
agreement and he just wanted her out of
the house he's there with his children
so so that's understandable now the
second case really has to do with this
NDA and she wants to be able to talk
about things and I wrote the complaint
and she is using the statute speak out
and she is also saying there is no
sexual harassment at this point in time
maybe that'll come out later but that
statute is supposed to be used to open
up an NDA when there are sexual
allegations and we don't see that yet so
I don't know what's going to happen
Brian between the NDA case the
allegation he kicked his ex out of the
home fewer Tiger Woods which one would
you be more worried about maybe you
wouldn't maybe none of these are
actually of concern to him I mean Jesse
like Tiger Woods and the Masters in 2019
when he won I don't think he's worried
because if you look at the one case
right I've never heard and I've lived in
Virginia Wisconsin New York
Canada I've never heard of an oral
agreement to allow someone to stay those
are flimsy and oral agreements can be
out the door just like it seems like she
was when he decided to change the locks
that sounds like an angry ex-girlfriend
and then you have this sex act case on
this face it looks horrible if there are
sexual assaults or harassment
allegations which we do not believe or
at least Herman's lawyer is saying they
do not believe there are as of yet so on
both sides I say wait for the
information but I don't see anything to
worry about right now okay so he's got
to worry about winning the next major
that'll be his main
concerned Brian Terry good to see you
both we're going to see everyone next
time as we discuss Justice in America
[Music]
thank you